unbeatable  i'll play some gambit against udem so if  he plays knight f6  yes let's play g4  some weird gambit  but that's why  anatoly is one of my favorite players  i think not just me  g5  oh i played them already  with them already played okay i forgot  well let's try to trap his knight then  we'll play a5  there we go he he uh  he must have mouse  he must have mouse lipped and played a6  can i get a game too sure  yeah i guess i didn't realize that uh  i already played with them but let's try  to make it quick queen g4  knight s3  h4  you ever jump back and join me and got  my first  first game your gm title yeah i i was  i was quite old already when i became a  gm fourth i was 14 in in one month  something like that  i want to play the king's indian if i  get black sure  bishop takes  x  95  check  it's 151 am for me okay so i should play  you next  that way you can go to bed  oh thank you jd cesar  i actually think  you